hey youtubers it's Charlie, this is going to be my Legend of Korra Episode 11 video
like Mike and Brian said shit just got
real in case you did not know next week
is going to be a two-part finale
episode 12 an episode 13 will post at
the same time
episode 12 is called the day and the
Colossus an episode 13
the finale is called the last stand new
enter the giveaway starts right now I'm
giving away another copy of the book
3 DVD 82 enters be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video
givers bowlers if you have it in the
episode yet but starting with top five
moments
number five Julie returns to Varick I
like the implication that now julie is
going to be more of a partner to him
probably been a sexual partner to
eventually I mean it seems like that's
the direction they're going
as socially retarded as Barrick seems
wheels and an awesome shot at
hummingbird factory
even though most of them seem like they
got destroyed I think if you love will
survive
and I'll be able to use in the finale
I'm really hoping that Asami in Baruch
get the pilot one by themselves
maybe so but it has since taken one
together or lease berrigan Julie
back she seems more natural if you like
the platypus bear all over again
owner did part many other that too does
when I fear it very Julie moments from
book to
lot of things about but two people did
not like but I totally love the parting
platypus bear
I muscle really hoping the Julie helps
very build a bigger version
EMP weapon because right now that's the
only way unless they have like
a buncha metal benders the committal Ben
that giant mech number for the big
montages the United forces rollout
I feel like I heard a collective cheer
from Tumbler when Prince iro showed up
and every word asking when he was coming
back don t Basco hasn't been on the
series in a while
but the first time we heard em in
recognized him as the originals ago I
was just so much fun
same time he shows up its recall that
should also be a cue to listen for other
original avatar voices for characters in
the finale
even if the original characters don't
show up in like Altaf orkut are all do
go
doesn't for the voices from the original
actors maybe another character's
is an amazing visual sequence just
showing everyone vacating the premises
the fleet moving into position career a
pretty much took most of them out
whenever she fire the laser the first
time
I don't think she just read all their
forces she is destroyed a couple the
ships in the bay
if you wonder why general I wrote with
on one other ships he's the commander up
the United Republic forces
so he's a good the general the entire
army so he moved to that ten on land
because they were planning on meeting
her on the battlefield
and even though she has their giant mech
she still has a shitload a tank in
regular size makes
as the end of the episode they have
surrendered but they do have some forces
left
like the United Republic forces are
completely decimated
number three core takes the air benders
the capture but our junior
Airbender mission impossible this is so
much fun I love the infiltration core
with just those hand movements I wish we
had more that I wish we had more time
I thought I was opening the chorus said
Miller couldn't go because his parts
were liability
are bending not an asset to
cloak-and-dagger operations
before this I never thought of him as a
uncontrollable farter
use the heaters parts thank you to grow
as people out I think my favorite for
bending moment from the season so far
though is when they go to this want to
bike or a
any tries to part bend the spear pine
evolve into some styles introduced
during legend according the series just
in general
I'll tip are bending probably one of the
best I just picture me lo in 40 years
with another picture at that fish vendor
next ending making a giant fart sound
levitating off the ground
it would be perfect next all the avatar
pictures number two
the first reveal the mecca godzilla
kubera so many awesome things going on
in the scene
for stop I just like Godzilla right off
the bat so nice
omar's took I do films mixer huge thing
and animate but they kinda already did
next
this is just super size makes seek the
Neon Genesis if you want to look here is
not bonded to the Mac
that is a pretty interesting idea though
there's so much good mech enemy out
there
is only a matter of time before recorded
their version of it a good to see
everyone in the back in their mind is
going let them fight
into I don't think it'll be as simple as
core going into Giants beer
form in smashing the Mac she did go into
the Avatar State when they were
interrogating but our junior
but she immediately went out anti threat
it makes me feel like they're saying
she's not going to go into the Avatar
State
to crush that dynamic other there's no
way she's not going to go into the
Avatar State for some reason
I don't think it's going to be to kill
could be ra other that option
is kinda on the table now especially but
our junior now it seems like
he's realized the coup Vera has betrayed
him in my number one
WTF moment of course
could be ripped fires the laser on but
our junior ancora it was a heartbreaking
but are do you see the live drain out of
his eyes it seems like there's nothing
that could be wrong but not due to
accomplish our goal now
they really do want to paint her as the
big bad for certain period
they wanted you to be little confused as
to whether or not her intentions were
noble
what she was trying to our ultimate goal
was now we know Jesus gonna step
on everyone she can it so she gets what
she wants I like that cause she had
earlier this season
I always get what I want who live in a
slippery slope for her
the only thing that I really want that
we haven't got yet is an explanation for
why she's so hardcore
we get the scene where she broke from
sioux yen Ritchie said I'm going to fix
things
but why did she feel so strongly about
that that's the question
so there was something super tragic that
we don't know about yet it happen when
she was a very little kid
it seems that the one as to not focus on
that but i just want to see what's going
on right here
not to overanalyze for back story too
much maybe make a brain just want us to
see her as this
immovable object I did think it was
interesting that she sighed a little bit
before cheap are the laser
a duty she loves but our junior but she
wants to accomplish her goal more
so she wasn't lying when she said she
wanted to marry him aged
she feels like this is the only way to
accomplish your goal she's posed to be a
tragic bill into she's not
outright evil that he wasn't playing him
for the for the whole time
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and do you think
the coop era
was lying about the torture you the
whole time Rd did she really does love
him
to some really important things to think
about as we head into the two-part
finale
a couple those hummingbird next probably
survived if anyone's gonna fly I'm are
expected be Julian Varick
Asami my kit 12 I don't know who the
palate with her
but there to fight they're going to be
happening to be the fight on the ground
and I'll be the fight with the giant
mech so team core is going to split up
for a little bit
like the original team core in the
younger members I miss the EVE teen
chorus like all the main characters
it really is could be reversed as
everyone else so team Korea is now like
everyone who is not with Cu Vera Patel
the next episode a the closest
implies that the Mac the giant makers is
going to cause a lot more troubled
the last and is obviously going to be
teen chorus Hill Mary pass
they've been a lot of theories about
line turtles core reconnecting with past
avatars
even her
theory that Air Temple alan has its own
set of statues in the past avatars
and they'll come to life and how bout to
this is built like a very personal
season so
I actually think when it all goes down
in the final moments it'll just be cora
in coop era there won't be anyone else
around that's kinda the way the ended
things with the original avatar series
I don't think the thing it does I had
quite the personal relationship the corn
cool beer have
did have quite the same history but I
like the idea that the bay fung family
drama
has replaced because family drama thank
you have a family a war
you have a nation at war although I
think that but our junior is going to
come back
I think this big man with the laser the
career firing on him I think that turned
the tide
the only other option is for him to die
with Cooper era he might actually try to
do that
in the other really big thing that we
need to consider is what's going to
happen with the spear by the Republic
City
there were some very prominent shots
them covering the city
they haven't done anything thus far the
spirits have remained absent
I feel like the vines are going to be
very important to this final battle
with our core uses them or the spirits
do something or the vines n8
the particle I internal some others are
long shots some other merle moralistic
I think the court will bend the vines to
help out but let me know where all your
big predictions but would you like to
see in the finale
and everyone want to see the original
team avatar members come back just over
a general I give the episode a saute
it was a great UEA for what's going to
be a totally crazy finale
it's going to be like a nonstop right
best now remember we haven't hit the
peak yet so it's gonna continue to
crescendo
like the action will continue get
crazier to the midway point
the climax will come when cordis has
some giant perot attacked
animation definitely top notch Megan
Bryant spent an extra time doing
reshoots with the actors
I'll be interested to see which seems
they did or if they change scenes after
the fact minute the way to the DVD comes
out in March to find out on the
commentary
hope we will be posting on social media
they're pretty good about posting to
tell more about little bit behind the
scenes the better episodes are released
and I'm sure after next week's episode
I'll be doing a buncha Q&A's
to talk about all the characters right
now I am actually really happy with
where everyone's at
kind even showed up and everyone was
asking where the Hells can I when is he
coming back
I was surprised to hear that so many
bugai's were fans at his and oh my god
bryan said that this isn't going to be
like a big bending contest between corn
could be right like the final battle
but there will be a battle it'll just be
stop-and-start core is just not gonna
let everyone diana's giant bloodbath
weeks I know if you're wondering how she
built that Mac
that's what I think she did with the
domes that she disassembled in South who
remember the first thing she said when
she rolled in was disassemble the domes
and then we never found out why I think
this is why so
very exciting finale I don't think it's
going to be as simple as a David and
Goliath situation with Koren the giant
mech
but whatever ends up happening I'm sure
all cry a lot and it'll be a lot of fun
cuny tomorrow so extra links appears
you're on your mobile.phone Airtel
actually think it's over here now the
heat in with the links are
the same as the links break here so
click here for the queue in a video up a
set tomorrow
in click here for all my other core
videos thank you so much for watching
the top high five I will see you guys
tomorrow